let's make chinese style tomato egg man  i love this dish but not always i'm  particular about it this is one of those  dishes that everyone makes differently  and tastes a bit different at every  restaurant some like it light some like  it indulgent all sauced up some  preferred stir-fried and less saucy i  personally prefer it slightly soupier  with the tomatoes on the softer side  clean and simple with the stars of the  show being tomato and eggs it's  affordable and simple comfort food i  don't think i'll ever really get sick of  this dish my mom made it for me and my  brother since we were little kids fast  forward to adulthood still making it i  like to top it with some garlic salt  sesame oil and green onions to add that  extra brightness to the dish pair it  with some deliciously fluffy steamy hot  rice and i promise you will not regret  this